when I work I get money from tourists
and now no half tourists and not have
the money how I can survive
how I can alive if the bearing a mass
it's mean no things no money no work no
people Buffalo no I don't have money you
put they are hungry they need a full
prostitution may be illegal in Thailand
but it's also a multi-billion dollar
business so what happens to the sex
industry in the age of coronavirus and
the hundreds of thousands of jobs that
rely on it
[Music]
you
lockdown is easing in Thailand but the
lights are still off in pitayas once
bustling party district
it's here in the city's bars sex worker
Anna used to meet most of her clients
happiest Athene neighbors leave and now
is very quiet this is what walking
street looks like in the past attracting
millions of visitors every year but in
March Thailand declared a state of
emergency due to covin 19 clubs and bars
have shut down tourists have gone
business has dried up before I earn like
a thirty thousand bucks for a month
our is the two or three thousand deep
end with remake equipment to cater with
our customer so 75 pounds and now and
now one week 1000 is that hard for you
to live very hard because I had to pay
rent pay for food every day Anna now
earns less in a week than she did in an
hour it's already been three months
without work there's no guarantee when
trade will return to normal it's
estimated between a hundred thousand and
up to a million people here in Thailand
gets some sort of money from the sex
trade but overnight the bars closed the
income stopped there was no warning
[Music]
charities safe attire is home to around
50,000 sex workers shut out at the bars
they used to work from they now look for
clients on the streets no money no work
no more now I can leave I can do because
no more people really really hurt me and
one sells sex by the beach before some
sex workers got some protection from the
clubs now they're even more isolated and
vulnerable a single mom with a young
daughter and nephew to feed this is a
devastating situation for me
60% of sex workers here and mothers they
say they have no other way to feed their
family how worried are you about
catching the corona virus from a client
street prostitution is one of the most
dangerous professions in the world and
now added to the constant risk of
violence arrest and sti's is the highly
infectious covert 19 to try and reduce
the risk local charities swing is
designing coded safe sex kit we have to
spay alcohol spray on the baby this is
the type of general anti bacterial
shower gel do we have to add all the
customers have to take a shower with
this we not try to spend for long-term
bitter customer in hotel we are scared I
can say be a scare about the Kuwait but
we cannot stop work so is this the
future of safe sex in a covert nineteen
world does that make make make us more
comfortable more confident to work be
hard we cannot stop
if a client says no I'm not wearing a
mask what does a sex worker say no math
nor thick and nor are oh six encoded
nineteen isn't the only risk poverty is
also a massive problem because
prostitution is illegal in Thailand sex
workers can't officially apply for
unemployment support so many are relying
on charity swing is now also giving out
almost three thousand free meals a week
two struggling sex workers they're gone
in minutes it's a slick operation but it
isn't enough it's claimed 50% of Qatar's
female sex workers have left it's never
been this difficult this is not just
don't need a sex worker we die we make
the people who are in behind them we die
also die because they don't help you
come to to survive themself it's not how
serious you think then this could that
get that people sit down the people they
are hungry they need a food they are so
sad because they don't know how to get
the money to to use their life and then
I wondering that it's okay for the for
the long term the people we we try to
kill themselves
[Music]
some of the sex workers who had jobs in
bars and clubs have been able to access
a state handout of around 400 pounds and
the government told us it can also help
them to find other jobs and cheap
accommodation but that potentially means
outing themselves as prostitutes and
many are afraid they'll be punished for
breaking the law this is my dress for
work some like Hanna are trying to ride
out the crisis hoping her regulars will
return when the boarders reopen she's
now selling jewelry on the Internet to
tighter I got her I got it I'm like some
friends she won't sell sex I not do it
online because I not trust the people
from Internet sometime they make a fake
profile like I put a handsome man the
more do like my soak I sometimes open
the room and see like oh my god Jason
can I turn turn back and go back but
when I go already so the show must go on
but behind the smiles kovat 19 has
pushed many to breaking point the sex
industry may bring in billions of
dollars a year here but the workers it
depends on have no rights no recognition
and some are now fighting to survive is
this the hardest it's been yes very hard
hottest in my life because I never seen
something like this before when I work I
get money from tourists and now no hair
turrets and not have the money how I can
survive how I can alive